all right hello evan preach first off
i'm like hello
we gotta say hello back [ __ ] that all
right first i'd like to say
thank you so so so so so so much for
existing after reading this i
already think i'm probably gonna test
you the amount of socials that you put
makes me think that you either a or a
teenager or b you haven't outgrown your
teenage years and still write like a
so um let's find out i want y'all to go
to your mamas and tell them that they're
angels for giving birth you're giving
birth to y'all
wait what would happen if you went to
your mom like thanks for giving birth to
me
that's what i'm finding right now is
there all of you going to answer
that
foreign
okay i love you super bowl kisses kisses
as i talk to my mom when she started to
turn up that she was funny
hello
are you okay you sound like you're
caught in a blender
i'm calling you for one reason i got an
email today from somebody who said to me
uh thank you tell your monk thank you
for giving birth to you
uh and tell her she's an angel sent for
heaven for giving birth to you
yes i'm sure what do you mean you're an
angel
no you said are you sure why did you say
are you sure
she said to me say to your mom thank you
say you know
mom you don't have to be insecure okay
just accept the fact that somebody
thinks you're amazing okay
okay you don't believe me huh
i just wanted to say i love you and i
appreciate you she
i shall see you soon she's like are you
sure your mom was like what you
what she had to she had to burst me
through a c-section so she's probably
like yo get the [ __ ] out of here they
have to provoke me
provoke you to come up that was he was
like yo i'm comfortable [ __ ] ain't
coming up
no but if they ain't happy i'm actually
pre-matured oh that explains a lot
i'm actually premature one i'm one month
premature
at eight months i was eight pounds so
you were fat you were premature
i was humongous if they waited another
nine months it would have come out like
a [ __ ] watermelon another eight but
another month i would have come out like
boom you know you've seen the movie
alien you had to come out like that
[ __ ] like for real
all right all right so we'll keep going
the problem i can't fix with my dumb ass
brain
we both agree i would really appreciate
your advice on so i'm being i'm in a
long distance relationship and i don't
know whether i should end it or not he's
the typical white [ __ ] boy
pineapple hair cringey ass words and a
lazy [ __ ] so why are you sending
us this email you already know all the
problems
he's white and i'm arab yeah i think
your people don't get along right now
um uh we've been together for two years
now and this things
are really starting to get bad his
father hates me because i'm arabic and
believes i'm going to recruit him to
isis
well this got very depressing he's
stupid
and i'm a medical student wow
uh he lives in the netherlands and i
live in australia oh yeah it's over
i have a feeling he's a gold digger
though i'm not sure i've spent almost
on his birthday presents this year [ __ ]
why
maybe she's really ugly i don't want
anything financial from him at all
because girls
because girls who ask for stuff are
hella annoying i like this girl a little
bit more than i did before oh jesus i
just got upset at the lack of effort
he's put into our relationship i'm
always
there when he has a problem but when i
hit rough times he chooses to run away
we're both average looking and also that
was never an issue
too she starts she's starting to work my
way into my heart i like this girl
i feel like i'm being way too sensitive
and at this point i'm completely stuck
and i don't know what to do
p.s he got me a card for my birthday and
not as i think you were sorry and you've
been
spending almost 700 worth of gifts on
him
i'm pretty inconsiderate and even that's
some next level [ __ ]
that's impressive to me i'm like [ __ ]
take me to your jedi school because i
don't even know how to do that [ __ ]
moves that you're pulling
uh you already know the relationship's
over like that you know you wrote a
long-ass email about all things you're
unhappy
and then you didn't write anything about
how positive you feel about the
relationship you're not optimistic
you're kind of just stuck in it so you
just need to accept that it's over and
move on make the [ __ ] call and
end it i'm just it's long distance girl
you need that dig in your life
so especially as a med student you're
going through a hard day you need right
you need a hard day after the hard day
you need a heart dip
you know what i'm saying you you know
you're going to be a doctor you're going
to need a dictator
no no yes no that's unacceptable
okay and look i'll also be honest with
you people who work in medical fields
people who are nurses who are paramedics
they tend to have very uh lavish
sex lives and the reason they they [ __ ]
around and they do all this crazy stuff
because they deal with so much crazy
[ __ ] that's gonna be you soon so get
yourself some local dick that you can
call
after a heart date who you're gonna call
some local dead
[Music]
better get your dick better better
yeah get yourself a heart dick is that
better
that's better all right listen all these
bad puns are dick and hard
it's over anything else you want to add
preach it's really hard to do that
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
so that's it for today's video be sure
to share like subscribe
comment leave comments because we read
it but we never reply
if you guys want to follow us we got a
youtube instagram patreon all that stuff
you know
share it
[Music]
we also have a sunday open mic that
happens every week here in montreal
details below
other than that see y'all soon next week
you know a dollar makes me hollow
how you doing